[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci d'être avec nous
dentiste à vos postes
ce soir on voulait absolument démarrer
cette émission par une minute de silence
suite au drame qui s'est passé vendredi
dernier puisque samuel pâti au fesseur
d'histoire géographie dans un collège
des yvelines a été sauvagement assassiné
par un terroriste notre émission est
énorme armand regardé par par les jeunes
par par les enseignants et ce soir voilà
on a tous bien sûr une pensée pour tous
les enseignants pour la famille de
monsieur paty et on a tous passé un week
end on s'est dit on veut pas de ce monde
là c'est pas un monde dans lequel on a
envie de vivre c'est vrai qu'en ce
moment il se passe des choses très très
pesant pour tout le monde et c'est vrai
que voilà on s'est dit c'est cesser
c'est pas de ce monde là qu'on veut on
aimerait alors c'est bête que je vais
dire ces essais et vous on aimerait un
monde d'amour c'est beaucoup plus simple
d'être dans un monde d'amour qu'un monde
de haine et j'ai ce qu'on aimerait voir
aujourd'hui sur tout et tout ce qui se
passe faut vraiment qu'on soit tous
soudés je vous le dis c'est un message
aussi que j'ai laissées sur les réseaux
sociaux ce week-end c'est vrai qu'on a
besoin d'être tous ensemble face à
l'adversité face à tout ce qui se passe
on le voit et ce qui s'est passé
vendredi à tous ça nous a fait passer et
nous ça nous a fait passer un week-end
dégueulasse on ne va pas se mentir parce
qu'on a tous pensé on pouvait pas
s'amuser comme on voulait ce week-end ne
pouvait pas même aujourd'hui on a tous
pensé bien entendu quand on s'est revus
et ce drame qui s'est passé vendredi
soir vendredi dernier faut plus que ça
arrive ça ça ne peut plus arriver